[Music]
and sometimes coffee makes me stutter
and i hate that oh yes it's almost the
end of the week clap you jerks you're a
bunch of jerks if you don't clap all
right shut up it's over
it's a thriller of a thursday look who
joined us
yeah brian kilmeade he's got a new show
on saturdays because apparently he's
cheaper than infomercials for non-stick
pants that is not true it's okay
and look who else is here degan mcdowell
you can still smell the moonshine on her
breath
i hope that's moonshine and she's not
drinking hand sanitizer again ugh the
things she learns from cat so do you
want to know how the media manipulates
the news well watch what happens when
they become the news
a stunner here at cnn today this morning
cnn president jeff zucker announced his
resignation effective immediately his
resignation is stunning this newsroom
and the news industry it's a tough day
here at cnn it is because this is a huge
surprise
and it leaves a leadership void
that's so funny
[Laughter]
they're shocked they just had no idea
including captain donut whose turf is
media scandal
so like my creepy baby shoe collection
this story just doesn't add up do you
really think this is about a
relationship between two consenting
divorced adults and if you do do you
mind sharing half of what you're huffing
with me
or does it feel like yet another story
created by cnn to dupe everyone else it
appears they already fooled their
anchors the equivalent of peek-a-boo
with an infant but cnn's the experts on
deflection first it was trump in russia
four years of hysteria which turned out
to be more fake than kamala's laugh
there was impeachment theater which kept
their viewers busy so they missed the
covet outbreak
and there's the crime wave something
that cnn mocked to deflect from their
culpability they made january 6th their
911.
fact is zucker should have been fired
out of a cannon into the east river over
those huge errors in those tiny tiny
ratings
but they're saying it's about a
relationship which is like saying al
capone was arrested for tax evasion it's
bs which stands for
and brian stelter
yeah like he was shocked well maybe he
was shocked that a woman would sleep
with zucker a guy who came in second
behind stelter in a george costanza
look-alike contest
when radar online was about to report on
zucker's indiscretion cnn had stelter
run a story aiming to discredit it and
that was a month ago when he called the
story garbage in a lie which sounds
exactly like something zucker would
order his minion to do
so he knew but it gets dumber the lady
zucker was romantically involved with is
alison gallust or go lust
a senior vp at cnn golist admitted the
relationship saying quote jeff and i
have been close friends and professional
partners for over 20 years recently our
relationship changed during kovid i
regret that we didn't disclose it at the
right time
so yeah it changed during covid like it
was a symptom of omicron apparently
their moderna jab came in the form of
cupid's arrow
that's almost as real as this great
moment in cnn coveted journalism all
right here it is the official
re-entry from the basement
cleared by cdc oh sweaty just worked out
it happens
this is what i've been dreaming of
you can dream a lot now
but the covered thing
it's a lie everyone knew about this
affair for years hell it was in katie
kirk's book and like don lemon's
stupidity it was accepted
so as i used to say to steve ducey when
he tried to sell me counterfeit viagra
i'm not buying it
not again
the outrage we're hearing about now is
just a cover like andrew cuomo killing
nursing home residents but getting
forced out for sexual harassment this
was the scandal that was convenient we
know fredo was secretly using his job to
help his brother and he got canned and
the lady that zucker was in a
relationship with also worked once for
andrew cuomo and according to the new
york post was helping him out now
it's like what we've always been saying
about the dnc and the media they're
literally all in bed together so this
isn't about the quote affair it's that
zucker was smart enough to use the
affair to get out of cnn on the tail end
of some other truly gross cnn scandals
that's clever timing he looks better but
what do i know i get all my investigated
chops from scooby-doo
when this whole time i should have been
watching to catch a predator
and yet they worry about joe rogan
becoming more trusted than their
pathetic station
not all opinions are created equal you
think about major newsrooms like cnn
that have health departments and deaths
and operations that work hard on
verified information october 19. and
then you have talk show stars like joe
rogan who just wing it who make it up as
they go along and because figures like
rogan are trusted by people that don't
trust real news rooms we have attention
a problem that's much bigger than
spotify
oh stop you're crying or you'll melt
yourself frosty
instead why not ask america why not ask
yourself why america trusts a stoner
more than they trust you but you got
bigger worries what happens to reliable
sources when your most reliable source
just resigned and who's going to protect
the anchors as they bleed more viewers
than a 50-pound sack of leeches
it's like the network has hemophilia but
it's funny the guy in charge of media
scoops misses the scoop right under his
nose
perhaps he was too busy watching fox to
see what was happening around him and
ignoring the obvious well that could be
dangerous
all right
great meeting everybody that's it for
today
so ted
i didn't get a chance to talk to you did
you do anything fun this weekend
uh
oh you know what i killed both nights oh
i didn't know you did stand up comedy
that's cool no no no no no i murdered an
innocent couple while they slept
a good one i can see why you're doing so
well at those clubs
you don't understand man i tortured a
husband and wife to death right right
that's good um dude were you cooking
with like raspberries or something it's
like oh oh no no no i actually uh
stabbed and drifter on the way here all
right sounds good ted i'll see you at
the two o'clock
no you won't
so
about cnn a famous man once said you can
keep painting a turd but that turd still
stinks that famous man was me i came up
with it while i was watching jesse
getting his makeup done
to me cnn is like a decent car that got
carjacked when it's recovered it's
defiled destroyed the upholstery's
shredded the seats are stained someone
peed in the glove compartment and the
owner wants the insurance company to
total it so he could just get something
new that's cnn a once decent network
that got carjacked by creeps who turned
it into a conflict-chasing conduit for
click bait if that sentence had any more
c's it'd be joe biden's report card
and like joe the brand is a shell of its
former self it's the joe biden of
networks old mean-spirited and can't
draw a crowd and constantly trying to
forget what it just did because it's so
embarrassing
cnn the most trusted name in ruse
i say tear it down start over get a new
boss who isn't the old boss i know just
the guy
yeah why not after all the crap that
went down over there this has to be a
step up
welcome tonight's guest
his new saturday show lets him ruin your
weekends too host of one nation with
brian kilmeade
co-host abundant friends
brian kilby
this southern bell went from attending
balls to breaking them fox business
anchor digging mcdowell
her therapist said they should see other
people foxy's contributor cat tim
and he puts a red light on his head to
warn landing aircraft my massive
sidekick and the nwa world television
champion tyrus
brian congrats on the new show and
finally naming it uh one nation it did
take a while yeah it did right glad to
see you're hopping on to the populist
bandwagon five years later right
my theory would stop my theory it's
actually scott adams that
zucker was
brilliant to leave now because of all
the other big scandals this looks small
and then it helps them cover up what may
else be hiding m what might be hiding
what say you oh fox and friends muse
okay i have a lot i'm going to go i'm
going to say something gut-fellish okay
they
paid off the refs they had the home
crowd they actually turfed the field
their own way they tilted the field
their direction and they still lost i
mean they went after they have all the
media that allow them to do everything
they they know that everyone's in their
pocket the government's in their pocket
and they still could not keep their act
together nor could they get ratings i
mean we glance at the ratings every day
we compete if you talk to people on cnn
they don't even know the ratings yeah
they have no idea we have to win every
day that's the way we're we're trained
this way we're bred but they're and they
don't get close and now they probably
don't want to see the ratings so he
leaves an epic failure think about this
he had the today show in his twenties he
helped turn it around since then he had
katie couric's talk show last maybe one
year then he went to nbc had that
brilliant idea having conan o'brien take
over and then he panicked and he put jay
leno back and then put him before and so
they go okay you're destroyed you lost
your reputation to destroy the late
night franchise so go to cnn and in in a
very short time he was fixated on trump
had a moment
could not get off trump they still can't
get off trump january 6th and now he
failed and he leaves in disgrace the
only thing i would i would say is this
is we know a fraction of the story but
he loses the ability to tell his side
now he lost his microphone but that but
the thing is is the other reason why he
resigned is so he doesn't have to answer
any more questions in court i don't know
i'm not a lawyer could be court i do
tell girls that at the bar right
oh i like that wow did you just notice
that toscanini yes wow um you know degen
okay this is a problem for me maybe not
a problem for you they cannot get rid of
stelter if they get rid of stelter i
lose so much editorial content and i
can't bear that what am i going to do
there's only so much droid read to go
around well
tyrus tried to counsel you on an earlier
show about getting off the stelter teat
yes yes and they're large they're hard
to turn down
but i think that you might need to you
know you need to work on that over the
weekend okay to find another source of
material i i think like why wasn't the
dude fired for
ratings yeah
he's an executive you're a business
leader you get canned purely for that
reason they don't even have one show in
cable news in the top 20. yeah so and
you know why because they don't program
for the viewers as a viewer if you turn
cnn on it's like being downwind from a
hog farm or like driving by that paper
mill on the way to the beach you're like
oh my god what is that smell
instead they program for well he
programs or did by his own ego
and then he uh and then the anchors are
just there to moralize and sniff his ass
or their own asses
so like what did what did alice and
camerota said he had this uncanny
ability to make every one of us feel
special and valuable in our own way
it's not about you it's about the
viewers yes
i could i could go on but it's like
i i just i have a lot to say it's like
jeff zucker because you do analogies
it's like he was running a sandwich shop
that only served head cheese because he
liked head sheets that's a actually
you're absolutely right it's somebody
who opens a business that sells
something that he likes and no one else
likes it's like i'm going to open a
record store and it's going to be
nothing but i don't know see i should
have thought about it
cheap trick i love cheap trick right
that's what i'm saying that's your
record store yeah yeah and it's like i i
may not see anybody for weeks right and
then some guy might just walk by go
cheap trick surrender yeah surrender i
remember that song and then they just
leave and i'm going yeah that that made
my day right no that's true though but
then i was like think about it tyrus
stelter is the media watchdog and he's
pretending that he missed it do you have
any new theories
no but i have a uh image in my head that
is going to take years ago
if there's any artists watching the show
tonight if you could please draw me a
picture of baby gut filled wrestling in
stelter's bosom that would be
so amazing but you got to be a good
artist yeah no you know what i don't
think you have to be i really don't
think you have to but a good artist
would be great but i'm worried about you
yes i'm worried about you because
you he has been your nemesis i got to go
to cnn rehab you guys you the tail of
the tape he's not going anywhere he's
got you by a few pounds but you got
around the same height he
takes this well not anymore
you know i i mentioned i walked by your
office today and i said hey
yeah
because apparently from inside cnn
they're calling for him to be fired yeah
because they're blaming him right or
it's probably like he was the teacher's
pet yeah and was walked around everybody
had to be nice to him and listen to his
jokes and because if you don't he's
gonna tell zucker on you and you're
gonna get pulled from tv and now
zucker's gone and all of a sudden
stelter's in trouble i feel like we've
become espn about cable news yeah you
really have he's about to get cut and i
suggest you get a small little high
chair yes and just have him sit there
and every once in a while you just smack
him in the back of the head oh god he
could be my little dr evil cat
cat um do you have any theory did you
see in the new york post they said that
that there's new information that him
and his sucker and his girl were helping
helping the governor appear on his
brother's show that's not surprising
what what is what piques your curiosity
again i just think that there's so much
more there has to be and i actually
don't believe that everyone knew i think
that most people did but the one reason
i think maybe everyone didn't is because
it's so boring right like
gossip is supposed to be interesting yes
if somebody came up to me
right if somebody came up to me and was
like these two people at my work they're
both divorced and they're doing sex
why are you talking to me don't ever
talk to me again that is great that is
actually like if somebody came to you
with that kind of gossip you would like
get away with anything else
they're adults they're in their 50s and
they're seeing each other
how dare you
consensually
[Music]
here's the thing they had a preservation
order cuomo's lawyer has a preservation
order of text messages between her and
the governor saying what's going on here
is she going to say that it was all
right allison gault's idea yeah to have
cuomo go on with cuomo yeah and is that
is that going to be his chris cuomo's
case
it was they were working with little
cuomo to protect big cuomo squashing
stories yeah changing the focus make
helping battle strategies so he's gonna
make his case worse he's gonna make it's
gonna be if i'm going down i'm going
down with you there you're coming with
me he's not gonna fall on the sword all
right he's not being fredo taking
quickly zucker was gonna get fired
anyway i think that's right warner media
and discovery are merging john malone at
discover um on the
on the board at discovery doesn't like
the way cnn was being run number one
number two this prevents them from the
um paying out the 18 million to chris
cuomo because they got rid of him
they're like we're not because cuomo
went to 18t who currently owns them and
said hey
um i'll rat on jeff zucker and they said
we don't care buy zucker and now you're
not getting your atm you wanted to brag
about doing sex all right i like my
theory but what the hell get after it uh
we can we gotta make some calls we do
we gotta get cuomo but we gotta get them
all back we gotta do an alternate cnn
universe so i can still be happy hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else